normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
speak the truth I mean since Ronald
McDaniel took over call her out call her
out 2018 2020 20122 no red wave that
never came we got trounced last night in
2023 and I think that we have to have
accountability in our party for that
matter R if you want to come on stage
tonight you want to look the GOP voters
in the eye and tell them you resign I
will turn over my yield my time to
you people cheering for losing in the
Republican Party think about who's
moderating this debate this
should Jo and Elon Musk we'd have 10
times the viewership asking
questions voters actually care about
bringing more people into our party
totally you think the Democrats we got
Christen weler here you think the
Democrats would actually hire Greg
Gutfeld to host a democratic debate they
would that's great use cuz this is
actually about you in the media and the
corrupt media establishment see the
Trump Russia collusion hoax that you
pushed on this network for years wow was
it real or was that Hillary Clinton made
up disinformation answer the
question
you whoa did he just knock did he just
knock uh what's her name out of second
place election they rigged the 2020
election with the hunter Biden laptop
story and they're going to rig this
election time is up
honestly maybe the best line out of all
the debates that there's been
was best opening of debate I think I've
seen my whole life Christie why you and
not former president
Trump you said it at the beginning of
the debate we are dealing with
extraordinarily important issues facing
this country right now wait are those
crbs on shirt Ally in the Middle East
fire from group that
has them and every Jewish person in this
world off the map we have Ukraine with
Vladimir Putin a communist KGB dictator
who wants to put the old band back
together he's starting in Ukraine and
he's going to move to the baltics and
Poland after that no he's not no in this
country that is choking choking every
American family that wants to try to
rise up
and give their children a better life
and tonight we need to decide which
President is going to be the one to
tackle the big issues who's going to
make this country look once again not
just inward but look outward at the
world and say America is the country the
indispensable nation that makes this a
safer world and in a safer World
American innovation American hard work
has always been the thing that has
driven our country to greater things I'm
going to be the president who will do
those big things we're not going to be
small and I'll say this about Donald
Trump half of their life focusing on
keeping themselves out of jail and
courtrooms cannot leave this party or
this country needs to be said plainly
Governor thank you let me turn to
Senator Scott Senator Scott you've said
former president Trump can't win make
your case to Republican voters well
certainly none of what I would say
without any question is that the truth
of my life destroy the lies of the
radical left we need a president and a
candidate who will actually help our
base solidify and attract independent
voters into our party the great
opportunity party is now winning back
African-American voters and Hispanic
voters because we are working on a
foundation based on faith our nation is
facing some deep challenges it is the
loss of faith in this nation that is a
part of the erosion that we're seeing
every single day it's restoring Faith
restoring our Christian values that will
help this nation once again become the
city on the hill when Ronald Reagan
talked about the city on the hill he was
coming from Matthew 5 when President
Lincoln talked about A House Divided
that was Mark our founding documents
speak to the importance of a faith
Foundation you don't have to be a
Christian for America to work for you
but America does not work without a
faith-filled judeo Christian Foundation
I would be the president that helps us
restore faith in God faith in each other
and faith in our future without that
Focus none of the issues the policies
matter we have to get back to being a
nation that is in fact the city on the
hill that believes in each other enough
for us to fight for that
when I just want to say real quick the
didn't answer the question about why he
should be the president over Trump oh
yeah just showed us why it's an
impossible question to answer you don't
want to piss off the Trump base but he
knows how to answer the question in a
political way oh yeah
100% Ian's right he just demonstrated he
demonstrated the kind of leadership the
kind of aggression the kind of
confidence that you want in someone that
would be command Chief and didn't anger
Trump if he
wants
to do at this moment Governor SZ I would
be telling BB finish the job once and
for all with these butchers they're
terrorists they're massacring innocent
people they would wipe every Jew off the
globe they could he cannot live with
that threat right by his country that
Hamas should release every hostage and
they should unconditionally surrender
I'm sick of hearing the media I'm sick
of hearing other people blame Israel
just for defending itself we will stand
with Israel in word and in deed in
public and in private and I can tell you
as Governor I actually did something
about it Biden's neglect has been
atrocious uh we had Floridians that were
over there after the attack he left them
stranded they couldn't get flights out
so I scrambled resources in Florida I
sent planes over to Israel and I brought
back over 700 people to safety there
could have been more hostages
the lack of specificity in the opening
is the problem because us through Iraq
and
Afghanistan been saying feel like hey
let's we want to break this open to a
huge Wide War instead of targeting Hamas
so there's a difference between words
and deeds we acted and we saved lives
thank you Ambassador Haley what would
you do what would you be urging prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu to do would
you consider humanitarian pause for
example the first thing I said to him
when it happened was I said finish them
finish them and the reason is I worked
on this every day when I was at the
United Nations and we have to remember
that they have to one eliminate Hamas
two support Israel with whatever they
need whenever they need it and three
make sure we bring our hostages home we
need to be very cleare eyed to know
there would be no Hamas without Iran
there would be no Hezbollah without Iran
there would not be the houthis without
Iran and there wouldn't be the Iranian
militias in Syria and Iraq that are
trying to hear hit our military men and
women if it hadn't been for Iran and who
is funding Iran right now China is
buying oil from Iran Russia is getting
drones and missiles from Iran and there
is an Unholy Alliance we need to be
clear eyed the last thing we need to do
is to tell Israel what to do the only
thing we should be doing is supporting
them and eliminating Hamas it is not
that Israel needs America America needs
Israel they are the tip of the spear
when it comes to this Islamic terrorism
and we need to make sure that we have
their backs in that
process of theere in regards to this
Islamic terrorism it's causing it I
think she means the tip of theere in the
war against Iran personally I think she
means like they're going to be the first
bodies sacrif I would go one step
further the founding vision of Israel
was based on the idea that they don't
want to depend on anybody else's
sympathy or Direction in defending
themselves so what I would tell BB is
that Israel has the right and the
responsibility to defend itself I would
tell him to smoke those terrorists on
his Southern border and then I'll tell
him as president of the United States
I'll be smoking the terrorists on our
Southern border that's his
responsibility this is our
responsibility that's how we move
forward but I want to be careful to
avoid making the mistakes from the
neocon establishment of the past corrupt
politicians in both parties spent
trillions killed Millions made billions
for themselves in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan fighting War
of
ourter did not Advance anyone's
interests adding trillion to our
national debt and Joe Biden sold off our
foreign policy Joe Biden's son Hunter
Biden got a $5 million bribe from
Ukraine that's why we're sending $200
billion back to that same country the
fact of the matter is the Republican
party is not that much better you have
the likes of Nikki Haley who stepped
down from her time at the UN bankrupt or
in debt is was her family then she
becomes a military contractor she joins
the board of Boeing and otherwise and is
now a multi-millionaire so I think that
that's wrong when do Democrats do it
that's the choice we face do you want a
leader from a different generation who's
going to put this country first or do
you want Dick Cheney in threein
heels Oh
no you're the president you're on the
phone in the oal office with the Prime
Minister he's been working on these a
while need the Joe Rogan meme from the
UFC
fire responsibility right to wipe Hamas
off of the map we will support you we
will be there with you we'll stand
shoulder Tosh shoulder there will be no
daylight but I would change the the
station a little bit though and head
back home to to America I would say to
President Biden diplomacy only is a weak
strategy appeasement leads to war
from President Obama to President Biden
Obama sent Millions to Iran frankly
President Biden has sent billions to
Iran that is why I've said that there's
blood dripping from the hands of
President Obama and President Biden I
would tell President Biden with great
clarity if you want to stop the 40 plus
attacks on military personnel in the
Middle East you have to strike in Iran
if you want to make a difference you
cannot just continue
Syria on warehouses you actually have to
cut off the head of the snake and the
head of the snake is Iran and not simply
their prox in order for us to have a
powerful response every time from
America we're not sending our young to
strength un States my forign policy
not Technic Advanced Army Senator Scott
thank you I want to get you in here look
Lester these problems are so big and
serious that the first thing I would say
does he keep making size references I'm
trying to be responsible here matter
what it is you need at any time to
preserve the state of Israel remember
that hamas's main goal is to get rid of
Israel is to get Israel absolutely off
the map now there are three things I
think I would say to him when he asked
for advice the first I would say is that
it is absolutely your obligation to all
right real quick I got to read the Super
Chat from Daniel TR uh trunks trink he
says I'm confused Dick Cheney and 3in
heels is he talking about Nikki Haley or
Ronda
s it creates greater unrest in the
entire region second you must go in and
make sure that Hamas can never do this
again the fact is that Israel and their
intelligence Community failed they
failed here and they failed the people
the state of Israel and so we need to
work closely and better together to make
sure one that they're degraded and two
that we know everything that's going on
inside Gaza Strip when it's going on so
that something like this can't happen to
kill 1400 individuals again the third
thing is to keep your eye on the ball
make sure that we continue to isolate
Iran work with the reasonable nations in
the Middle East the other Arab Nations
who want to partner with you and make
sure that we continue to isolate Iran so
that their only friends in the world are
the part of the evil force China Russia
Iran and North Kore Christie thank you
very much and we're going to continue in
this vein right now with a question from
Matthew Brooks the CEO of the Republican
Jewish Coalition a partner of the
Republican National Committee in this
debate here it
is given attacks by Iranian back proxy
groups on US military bases in Syria and
Iraq attacks that have wounded
approximately two dozen of our US
service men do you support the use of
military force by the United States
against Iran no Governor Hy would you
please answer that yes I'd first like to
say they're 5 in heels and I don't wear
them unless you can run in them so she's
accepting she's Dick Cheney we got two
of you on stage he said you hear what he
said we got two of you on stage heels
they're not for fion statement they're
for ammunition what we need to be doing
for is first of all the idea that our
men and women could be targeted and that
we've allowed almost hits to happen
under Biden's watch is Unthinkable we
need to understand this is Iran giving
the green light telling them what to do
and we shouldn't be doing the tip fortat
like what Joe Biden has done we need to
go and take out their infrastructure
that they are using to make those
strikes with so they can never do it
again Iran
responds you punch them one and you
punch them hard and they will back off
but what we don't need is Biden falling
all over himself to get back in the Iran
deal him giving $6 billion to get five
hostages home him telling Netanyahu now
that he needs a pause or a ceasefire we
don't need him going and sitting there
tiptoeing around Iran because he thinks
they're going to do something you don't
respond to an enemy and a terrorist with
fear you respond with strength when you
do that that's when the world pays
attention and that's when Iran stops
thank you Governor dandis if I can
continue with you just today the US
launched another one of its limited air
strikes against Targets in Syria this
time Iranian linked facility how far
would you go militarily to hold Iran
accountable well first Matt thanks for
your question and I appreciate what
you've done over the last month I know
it's been very difficult for the
community and appreciate you guys
rallying together in difficult times uh
I actually served in Iraq back in the
day and um we had al-Qaeda in Iraq you
had Shia militias that were funded by
Iran that were killing
hundreds and hundreds of US troops and
as commanderin-chief I am not going to
put our troops In Harm's Way unless
you're willing to defend them with
everything you have Biden has them out
there they're sitting ducks he's doing
glancing blows that's just inviting more
attacks from the Iranians I would say
you you harm a hair on the head of an
American Service member and you are
going to have hell to pay we are not
just going to sit there and let our
service members be sitting ducks and
that's true whether it's Iran or whether
it's any country on the world we have to
be strong and we have to defend the
people who defend us all right thank you
Governor now our second and final
question for Matthew Brooks of the
Republican Jewish Coalition please
watch Jewish students across the country
are threatened and under attack yes they
are what do you say to Jewish students
on college campuses who feel unsafe
given the dramatic rise in anti-Semitism
and what do you to say to University
presidents and college presidents who
have not met the moral Clarity moment to
forcefully condemn Hamas terrorism it
was a professor who killed that Jewish
elderly man absolutely I think the
scourge of anti-Semitism across this
country including it places like my alma
moders and places like Brooklyn Bridge
in New York it's sad to see but here's
what history teaches us anti-Semitism is
a symptom of of a deeper cancer in a
country in a society that is lost and we
are lost several years ago when I wrote
my first book woke Inc I was talking
about they were chanting death to
America death to white people death to
Christians nobody was waking up back
then now it's even bad now they're
saying death to Israel and worse so it
is wrong but we have to get to the root
cause here now I think it's really
important that we do this through
leadership not censorship leadership
means fill that void with purpose and
meaning dilute this woke is M and
anti-Semitism to irrelevance these kids
they have no idea what the heck they're
even talking about when they're siding
with Hamas over Israel they are fools
but I also want to caution here if we go
the direction of Ronda santis or Nikki
Haley with whom I respectfully disagree
on this issue Pro censorship telling
student groups to disband mark my words
soon they will say if you question a
vaccine and it side effects you're a
biot terrorist soon they will say that
if you show up at a school board meeting
you're a domestic terrorist soon if they
say that j6 prisoners reled you're an
insurrectionist terrorist so that's
where this road ends we don't this with
censorship because that creates a worse
underbelly we quell it through
leadership by calling it out these
University administrators have lost
their way and we need leadership at the
top in the United States of America that
restores our founding values and that
has no place for this kind of
anti-Semitic hate that's where I stand
he texted me when r s made that move I
talked to him about it and he was
critical of what Ron did in shutting
down these groups despite the fact they
claim to be Hamas but I said I said that
to I was like hey man these these
they're claiming to be Hamas support
Hamas and then he said effectively he
saying he was like no way dude if you
let him make this move it's just a bunch
of dumb kids they're going to go after
everybody to our country I'm impressed
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net only shows exclusive thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next
time